جو وادهان
ر و
همنگجی زیر ابر تیره خفته
روی زواج عرف
فل اتاده به
خبزیک
مدر
روشnaیi
[Musique]
aşkbار
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
goulamali il venait de traduire en
langue d'Ar le dormeur du val d'arur
beau le vieil homme lisait des poèmes
pour oublier la
guerre lui et 24 autres anciens
interprètes afghans de l'armée française
vivaient dans la ville de Lan dans l'Est
de la
France ces interprètes venus des quatre
coins de l'Afghanistan avaient travaillé
au côté des soldats français contre les
talibans entre 2001 et
2014 tous avaient été rapatriés avec
leur famille alant tous tentai de
trouver leur place dans cette ville
située dans la diagonale du
[Musique]
vide nous on est on est venu
comme je
peux utiliser une expression comme comme
un
champignon dans la
forêt quand on se quitté
l'Afghanistan on a préparé
des bagages à peu près si bagages si
sacs en plus que les dimensions c'était
donné par l'ambassade qu'il faut pas
dépasser de ça c'était 70/
50 donc c'est ça c'est en respectant
tout ça qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre une
vie
de 40
ans alors il faut mettre dans les sacs
ça rentrera
jamais
les enfants aussi ils avaient des
souvenirs dans la maison dans les
pièce alors ils ont gardé leur jouet et
j'ai rangé leur jouet et j'ai numéroté
j'ai mis que c dans cette sac là il y a
ça ça ça ça ça c'est ton sac tu
viendrais un jour et tu tu
récupéris récupéreras tout t tes jeux et
là en réalité je me suis disais que dans
c'est c'est pas all retours mais c'est
c'est un c'est un aller sans
retour dans l'avion alors les stress et
les questions que je disais tout à
l'heure comment je fais je vais où je
seraai accueilli comment tout ça c'est
des des des questions que même les
enfants même mon épouse il disait il me
posait la question alors comment on fait
on a abandonné notre pays on a abandonné
une belle vie et est-ce qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en avoir ah mais je disais
mais pour la calmer toujours toujours
mais il faut il faut perdre quelque
chose pour avoir l'autre chose vous avez
perdu la guerre l'insécurité maintenant
vous allez vivre en paix c'est pas grave
si c'est une
tente
[Musique]
franchement je ne connaissais pas
beaucoup ni la culture française euh ni
d'autres choses par rapport à la France
parce que j'ai entendu que j'avais
entendu que il y a la liberté la
fraternité l'égalité
et tout ce qu'on veut on peut faire en
France c'est ça qu'en fait j'avais
entendu quand j'étais en Afghanistan et
quand je suis arrivé ici en France j'ai
vu que c'est c'est bien ça les femmes
les hommes sont mélangés ils vont au bar
et ils boivent du café et puis il se
discutent et tout ça une fois que je
suis arrivé sur le territoire français
j'ai vu en fait ça ça m'a choqué un peu
mais pas beaucoup ça m'a choqué un peu
et puis euh voilà depuis 6 ans j'ai de
l'habitude hein maintenant
voilà au débout nous avions espoir en
fait de rester en Afghanistan ne penser
jamais de venir en France parce que
c'était notre pays et on ne savait pas
que la la situation
sécuritaire euh se dégradé en fait pour
les interprètes ou pour ceux qui ont
travaillé avec l'armée
[Musique]
française
depuis que je me souviens il y avait la
guerre l'arrivée des Rous du
soviétique le jjihad la résistance
contre soviétique
l'arrivée des mjahidin la guerre civile
il y avait tout le temps une guerre en
fait et la guerre il nous a il a apporté
un malor aux générations des
Argons les afgans c'est pauvres ils sont
satisfaits avec un morceau de
pain un assiette pipinard et ça passe
les Français n'ont pas un niveau
économique ils ont beaucoup plus de
pouvoir d'achat ils vont au piquenique
ils vont à l'Égypte à l'étranger il en
profite de la vie ils cherchent des
richesses il cherchent des plaisirs dans
la
vie alors que les Afghans les pauvres
vous voule être vivant il est de quoi
manger il qu'il soit capable d'aller à
l'école et de moins ne pas avoir la
guerre et des des obou des chikoues qui
tombent sur leur leur maison c'est ça la
différence entre vivre et être
vivant les afgans voulent être vivant
mais les les Français il vouent
vivre ça va pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non c'est le meilleur partie de ma
vie parce que quand les Liban ils sont
venus à
Capou c'est la France qui nous a
sauvé c'était dangereux pour mon mari
pour mes enfants et pour moi parce que
tout le monde a dit que vous êtes des
espiones de la France
euh il disait que ton mari aussi il
travaille avec les étrangers avec les
Français et toi aussi avec les Français
et à cause de ça que nous sommes obligés
de venir en France pour sauver notre
vie
[Musique]
je connais la guerre j'ai goûté j'ai ça
m'a fait ça a été douloureux en fait
j'ai participé dans beaucoup des
missions de combat des patrouilles et
cetera environ 150 200 missions
euh mission sur le terrain et c'était
dangereux oui bien sûr l'interprète
jouait un rôle primordial c'était un
point de contact entre l'armée française
et la population afghane c'était
toujours interprète qui rentrait dans le
village en premier après la deuxème
c'était le chef de section soit c'était
le lieutenant ou sergent chef ou agent
chef qui sont renseigné en fait
concernant les Taliban et tout ça
c'était souvent les interprètes
qui apprendaiit la culture afghane aux
armées d'autan aux armées françaises
sans interprète l'armée française ne
pouvait rien
faire jusqu'à 2008 la situation
sécuritaire était calme en Afghanistan
même l'armée française sortait sans euh
gilet parabal sans VAP s FAMAS c'était
après 2008 que la la situation
sécuritaire a commencé à se détériorer
de jours en jour à chaque fois quand il
avait des opérations comme ça quand on
sortait euh de camp on était obligé de
se défendre c'était souvent le capitaine
ou le colonel qui nous fournissait les
armements on rentrait dans le village
parce queon a eu le les mêmes vêtements
comme soldat français avec G parabas les
personnes pouvait différencier entre les
interprètes et les soldats français et
il nous tiraent en fait il nous tirait
au-dessous de la fenêtre de la maison et
tout ça et on était obligé en fait de se
défendre mais on était on était pas bien
formé
mais on pouvait tirer on pouvait tirer
on nous a tiré dessous j'avais pas d'Ar
je j'insistais pas d'avoir l'arme ce
qu'on m'a dit j'ai fait mais j'étais
affecté en tant que pcrl personne civil
recruté de la locale en fait personne
locale j'étais pas soldat j'étais
interprète civil quand on m'a donné le
FAMAS je l'ai pris quand on m'a pas
donné j'ai pas insisté
ou ça c'est le c'est ouis ou ça
c'est
c'est le souvenir qui
reste
on estêt
humain c'est pas vrai qu'on se dit que
les Afghans c'est métallique ils n'ont
pas pe c'est pas
vrai nous pour ça on a un
proverbe chacun a peur le soir certains
le disent certains le
[Musique]
cach
quand on est dans la situation de guerre
on voit beaucoup de choses il y a des
soldats afghans il y a des soldats
françaises qui sont déjà blessés mort à
côté de toi pour nous moralement c'est
c'est très très difficile
d'oublier son 500 soldats ils ont étudié
ou entraîné pour que quand quelque chose
qui arrive il faut
l'oublier mais les interprètes nous
euh c'est un cauchemar pour tout le
monde pour tous les
interprètes je voulais démissionner
après après quand quand il n avait pas
de conflit je pensais que peut-être ce
sera pas répété voilà et puis et d'un
côté le capitaine le lieutenant de
l'armée française aussi il m'a encouragé
en fait de travailler voilà il m' donnit
du courage des courage voilà c'est fini
il n'y a pas d'autrre attaqu et tout ça
il y a pas la guerre à gagner c'est pas
la guerre de courage ou des sabres c'est
les armements chaud automatiques qui
fonctionne avec la puissance de gaz de
poudre ça n'a aucun ça n'a rien à voir
avec le courage une guerre gagné ou une
guerre pardout c'est c'est c'est les
Américains qui gagnent c'est le le monde
entier qui
P fin 2014 fin oui 2014 euh le général
général français alors il a fait ses
adieux alors il a remercié
coopération tous il a fait son discours
moi j'étais bon honoré de de faire
l'interprétation de de Goodbye party
quoi on peut
dire nous quittons aujourd'hui cette
académie avec une émotion
certaine vous le
savez la France ne fournira pas de
soldat pour la prochaine mission de
l'OTAN en
Afghanistan mais la France
restera à vos côtés donc après le départ
des Français alors ce premier cle
c'était les
interprètes les interprètes qu' ont
qu'ils ont travaillé avec l'OTAN ça
c'est premier C pour les taliban après
les officiers et les polices et il avait
50000 AFG alors pour un interprète pour
la tête d'un interprète sa récompense
parce que il disait que ça c'était les
interprètes qui étaient la langue les
pieds les mains même le cerveau de de
l'OTAN et ou bien des des des militaires
françaises euh ou bien étrangères il y
avait une grosse bombe un engin explosif
qui était dissimulé derrière la maison
c'était à 1h le matin qui s explosé la
il avait tris trois chambres
et c'est ce son effondré il y avait des
Bries des des Combres partout et nous
nous étions légèrement pas beaucoup et
c'était j'étais choqué en fait je
n'avais pas d'autres solution et puis
j'étais obligé de commencer euh de faire
la manifestation et de réunir tous les
mes collègues au parc charina de trouver
une solution et de sauver notre
vie on a donné les dossier
ou à la réponse le dernier jour il nous
a donné une courrier que c'était négatif
notre dossier ne répondait pas au
critères de la demande de la demande
d'asile ou d'être rapatrié ramené en
France ça on ne répondait pas aux
critères je sais pas quel critère ça je
sais pas j'ai décidé d'aller voir
directement un attaché militaire à
l'ambassade de France nous avons bien
expliqué que voilà euh nous sommes en
danger pourquoi nos collègues certains
nos collègues sont déjà partis en France
et pourquoi nous nous ne pouvons pas
bénéficier de la protection euh il nous
a fait partir en fait de
l'ambassade en disant que voilà
voà quel d'entre vous est mort pour la
France la même phrase et puis nous
sommes retourner chez
[Musique]
nous tout le monde ça c'est la question
qui posait même les officiers afgans il
nous posé que ah vous restez vous ne
partez pas avec les Français alors on
vous a abandonné com qu'est-ce que vous
faites on peut vous recruter ici les
collègues de de de du travail c'est les
Français qui me disaient alors que là
vous serez abandonné on part ici
définitivement vous serez comme
lesésarchis en Algérie pareil pareil ce
sera répété encore une fois voà nous les
afgans on fait pas ça facilement pas la
main on fait pas l'amitié mais quand on
le fait on le fait jusqu'au bout on
nabandonne pas notre ami au moitié de
chemin vous savez le c'est autorisé dans
l'islam dans dans les pays chez nous la
divorce mais les Afghans il le
pratiquent pas c'est h divorce on fait
pas le mariage c'est pas facile avec
chacun qu'on connaît pas mais après on
fait pas la divorce ben nous normalement
on n pas l'habitude de abandonner
quitter celui qui a fait de bien pour
nous de le laisser au moitié de Ch
surtout c'est pas c'est pas bon pour un
soldat en hom de combat c'est hors de
Honor et hors de question il aurait pas
dû nous
abandonner comme la manifestation
c'était complètement inutile il n'avait
pas de de journalistes il n' avait pas
de médias et tout ça à la dernière fois
j'ai décidé d'inviter deux journalistes
français un journaliste RFI et l'autre
journaliste était de France Press et
grâce à ces de journalistes on a pu
médiatiser en fait notre problème
quelques jours
après j'ai réussi en
fait de recevoir un message de la part
de l'ambassadeur de France et nous avons
réussi d'obtenir un visa mais pas tous
mais juste
[Musique]
certains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
pas il faut qu'on coupe CELI
[Applaudissements]
couper
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fenêtre on dit la h la h ou la cabane
quelle est la différence entre les deux
la h h e et la cane ça veut dire la même
chose mais je sais pas pourquoi on
nutilise pas
hon utilise la
[Musique]
cavane j'ai eu l'information à
l'ambassade à Kabou que vous allez vivre
àan j'ai regardé sur Google
Map j'ai vu la cathédrale voilà tous et
l'habitant les habitants de 26000
personnes c'est ça l'information j'ai
j'ai quitté ma mère et j'ai quitté
l'Afghanistan qui est comme ma mère
c'est on est très attaché à sa
terre quand on est descendu débarqué d'
l'avion il y avait colonel qui est venu
pour nous accueillir un colonel de
l'armée et après on est monté dans les
bus on est venu ici à 40 boulevir de Lon
avant on était tous ensemble dans la
dans un dans un bâtiment des mes
sous-officiers
sous-officiers et il l il faisait froid
il y avait une dame il est vous il a dit
c'était une vieille dame
oui il a dit je sait quand on vient
qu'il y a rien à la maison c'est
difficile ils ont ramené tout ce qu'ils
avaient je suis arrivé en France en 31
mars
2016 si je je me trompe pas c'était
samedi un samedi
pleuvait quelqu'un qui sait pas nager et
tu vous le mettez dans la mer alors
débrouille-toi c'était comme ça
ah on est arrivé devant un immeuble et
les gens qui nous accueillent et on
descend avec nos
bagages donc le seul choseavantage qu'on
avait que un appartement nous attendait
déjà il y avait il y avait des
chambres une de
TBL table grande table avec cette chaise
pour cette personne et cette
lit
voilà on était au centre de la ville 25
familles avec des cultures
différentes l'un qui vient de de des
provinces l'autre qui vient de centre de
Kabou l'autre qui vient de le Nord de
l'Est avec les enfants les vieux les
vieilles les jeunes les moyens
tous à cette époque là donc en 2016 on
était 102
personnes quand je suis venue ici
j'habitais dans un
appartement quand j'ai vu les femmes
afghanes ils ont mis tout le monde avec
des voiles des bourkain et comme ça et
euh sauf moi que je ne met pas de voiles
et toujours je ne sais pas il m' regardé
il dit à voilà madame il n met pas de
voile et comment il peut sortir de la
maison et voilà c'est tout et j'ai
demandé à mon mari il dit que ne pense
pas à ça chacun a sa sa vie euh si tu ne
veux pas de voile n mets pas si tu vois
tu mets ça ça
c'est ta décision il y avait des gens
des des interprètes qui sont venus avec
leur
leur vêtements vêtements traditionnels
centre la ville et les gens qui on nous
regardai alors ils regardaient c'est
quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe ici et
autour de nous les gensent inquiets
vraiment c'est très très inquiet ils ont
peur que qu'il sera vandalisé alors
voiture voler ou bien casser les les
carreaux et Cera et
Cera après un mois de notre arrivé on a
eu des signes sur les les le mur de
bâtiment
alors là ils ont que ils ont fait des
signes de
comme de
hitleruc des petites choses rentré c'est
un truc comme ça chez
vous après les les
les les assistants sociaux
ils ont nettoyé le jour même le mot
boucherchier c'était croix gamé
C TR gamé
ou
une fois que je suis arrivé sur le
territoire
français le travail que pour l'emploi
m'a proposé c'était de trier la salade
sur le tapis à l'entreprise de Dona qui
se trouve à l'an pourtant j'ai eu la
capacité de travailler en génie civil
j'étais un ingénieur j'étais aussi un
électricien après j'ai décidé de quitter
le travail et actu éement moi je
travaille en en qualité d'interprète
pour les immigrants afghans qui sont
déjà venus en France
oui donc il a une question docteur dans
combien de temps il va rester
hospitalisé ici chez vous et vous allez
le libérer dans combien de temps doctur
alors en fait il est pas du tout
emprisonné c'estàd que si sil s'en va il
s'en va on va pas le le poursuivre ni
laner les gendarmes ni quoi que ce soit
le problème c'est que lui il a une forte
suspici de tuberculose et le but
essentiel c'est de le protéger lui et de
protéger les autres migrants qui
habitent avec lui d'accord AINS soitil
il va pas contaminer d'autres migrant ou
d'autres peuples d'autres personnes mais
là il demande votre autorisation afin de
pouvoir partir au camp et récupérer le
cigarite ses affaires le téléphone et
après il va revenir dans la
foulée c'est
bon
[Musique]
d'accord ok il va
revenir il est fidè la parole donné il
va
revenir très bien vous le remerciez
beaucoup et vous lui dites qu'on prend
soin de lui avant tout ouis merci
Docteur merci que vous réfléchissez à sa
santé à lui-même à une personne qui est
V rentrer clandestinment merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup vous exilez un homme soit et
après vous pouvez arracher un arbre de
ces racines o n'arracherit pas le jour
de
Cal est-ce que tu as du jeune
après c'est moi qui l'a eu
non encore un miroir ici et ici il est
encore plus
[Applaudissements]
mort montre-moi qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est un arbre ah un arbre c'était un
arbre c'était en Afghanistan non oui ça
c'est bien dessiné le truc vert c'est
c'est les feuilles ah les feuilles de
l'arbre oui c'est bien et qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est c'est des voitures ah c'est
des voitures qui passent par la route
toi tu avais une voiture dorée dorée
exactement j'ai une voiture dorée et
votre angle matériel avait une voiture
rose comme ça je sais d'accord oh toi tu
as dessiner beaucoup de choses et
qu'est-ce que c'est ça ça c'est le
drapeau
d'afghanistanghanistan d'accord c'est le
drapeau ça c'est bah j'ai la robe
traditionnelle mais après j'ai pas
réussi du coup j'ai j'ai fait un autre
truc ça c'est le truc qu'on met sur
notre tête là avec beaucoup de bijoux
dessusp Bou dessus d'accord les fleurs
oui les poissons les poissons oui ça
vous avez bien dessiné quand je rentrais
de mon travail et je je m'allangeais je
pouvais
douter souens ça ça ça quand to as été à
la crèche il t'apprenit l'alphabet en en
Perse à
FBT voilà ça c'est les alphabets super
c'est bien ça
[Musique]
merci
quand j'étais jeune j'étais à l'école
l'école de lycée
stekal à cette époque les les femmes il
se maladent tout seul ils étaient en
pleine autonomie comme ma mère qui
faisait ses courses toute seule même on
allait au cinéma il y avait des cinémas
des
théâtres euh les portes des maisons
c'étit presque ouvertes on fermait pas
le Caden on surveillait même pas on
dormait tranquillement les policiers par
exemple les policiers il n'avaient pas
d'armes à cette époque ils venaient avec
un bâton il se baladait un petit bâton
alors donc le bâton qui représentait la
loi mais malheureusement avec la guerre
il est parti tout c'est
[Musique]
fini
quand j'étais jeune j'ai pensé à ça que
je serais être une présentatrice euh à
la télé mais malheureusement que ma
famille ne permet pas il a dit que non
ce n'est pas bien pour les filles euh ma
famille il son
h ouvert mais notre euh notre peuple ils
ne sont pas
ouverts après j'ai continué mes
études à l'université de Kabou
département de français j'ai choisi être
professeur aujourd'hui on commence la
première leçon de français et ce que je
dis il faut vous répétez c'est une
fenêtre c'est la porte comment
tappelle-tu
je qu'est-ce que c'est
ça prenez votre cahier et écrivez ce que
j'écris masculin et
féminin5 OK et ça c'est le diplôme de
quoi moi j'ai été dans le lycée
francophone parce que j'ai préféré la
langue français et la civisation
français à l'époque de monarchie tous
les étudiants de Kabou majorité ils ont
parlé français les membres du ministère
des Affaires étrangères étaient
francophon notre roi
am a voyagé en à Paris avec son re il a
écrit un contrat
culturel avec les la
France le fils du roi nous a invité dans
la piscine dans un jardin à pagm PM en
Afghanistan alors nous nous avons été en
train de nager que le roi vient avec euh
ses corps d'armées et cetera avec c'est
bodygordes alors notre corps était nu le
roi vient chacun demande des questions
en français parce que le roi a fait ses
études en
France sa famille on fait a fait l'étude
en
France alors le roi demandait de chacun
de ceux qui nageent il dit comment
s'appelle cet animal je dis ce n'est pas
un animal
c'est un oiseau il est comment àg il
s'appelle un canard il dit très bien et
d l'eau dans laquelle vous nagez comment
on s'appelle j'ai V piscine la
piscine bravo dit bravo
bravo après il a demandé d'autres
questions finalement le roi était très
content était retourné au à son en
Palais Royal à la veille de son départ
pour la France Sa Majesté a bien voulu
nous recevoir en son bureau du palais
gulhana vous savez qu'il est toujours
agréable ce dire ma joie de retrouver
bientôt la France à laquelle TS de
souvenir m'attache pour votre part vous
avez vécu en France vous avez étudié à
Paris au lycée gancon de sailli et à
Montpellier également oui mais il y a
longtemps de cela 35 ans je crois depuis
comme vous le voyez
j'ai quelque peu perdu la pratique de
votre belle
[Musique]
langue aujourd'hui il y avait une dame
infirmière m'a j'ai appris un mot son
dictionnaire côte les côtes les côtes
c'est ou
c'est après moi aussi j'ai appris un mot
quel mot
mode
sporidiquement il sporidiquement
sporidiquement d'accord et blafar
aussi le mot de blafar blafar moi ça je
sais pas je connais pas j'ai besoin
d'une phrase en français surcomposé à
l'imparfait
subjonctif passif en même temps
subjonctif passif
surcomposé comment comment on dit en
français c'est comme ça le
avec plus parfait passif subjonctif je
peux dire que juste ét aimé par exemple
comme ça avec l'imparfait que je fus
aimer mais
avec une phrase surcomposée dans
l'imparfait subjonctif passif en même
temps comment on dit en français
indicatif c'est un dictionnaire
mobile
dictionnaire
[Musique]
bonjour
c'est
maman hier l'après-midi on a terminé
l'extérieur vient voilà comme che vous
on pas fait
Paris vrai on a besoin du
temps un beau travail travail d'équipe
oui je sais oui que vous a vu à
l'œuvre je retourne chez
moi et
voilà de 2016 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les interprètes on a gardé
cette
liaison j'ai discuté c'est il dit que
voilà avec plaisir tu choisis le jour la
date et environ 7 h personnes il m'a
aidé pour construction de cette
caban après ici on peut passer le
temps avec ma famille avec nos collègues
qui viennent souvent ici pour faire un
barbecue pour prendre un thé un café et
ça c'est
vraiment le jardin c'est moi qui pris
mais le 25 familles
qui sont à côté de nous ils sont très
[Musique]
contents
j'ai monté mon dossier de naturalisation
j'ai envoyé deux fois trois fois quatre
fois
euh 6e fois j'ai renvoyé mais j'ai pas
de retour je suis en train de préparer
les papiers mais j'ai peur parce que si
j'ai fait une demande si elle me refuse
ça c'est triste c'était la préfecture
qui nous a accordé la carte de séjour la
différence c'est ça que avec une carte
de séjour on peut rentrer en Afghanistan
on peut retourner en France mais avec un
statut de réfugié on n pas de droit en
fait d'aller en Afghanistan on a de
droit de d'aller dans les pays européens
mais pas en Afghanistan j'ai juste une
carte d'ancien combattant qui est donné
par
l'ONAC le service d'ancien combattant
comme quoi que j'ai bien servi voilà
l'armée française c'est pour ça qu'on
est régulièrement on est invité à la
préfecture pendant la
cérémonie voilà pendant cérémonie
festival et tout ça de 14
[Musique]
juillet
thérèe laissa éteindre sa cigarette l'
fixe elle regarder cette cage au
barreaux innombrable et vivant cette
cage tapissée d'oraill et dieux ou
immobile accroupi le Mton au genou les
bras entourant ses jambes elle attendait
de
mourir teresse il est obligé d'oublir
euh la famille de sa de son mari et il
reste à la maison moi j'ai pensé aux
femmes qui habitent qui habité au région
d'Afghanistan et à cause de ça que j'ai
traduit ce
livre dès que les taliban ils
sontarriver à Kabou c'est fini à venir
pour les femmes c'est
fini seulement les les filles qu's ont
déjà 12 ans jusqu'à 12 ans 13 ans
ell peuvent aller à l'école après 13 ans
ou 14 ans ou 15 ans c'est fini
Afghanistan c'est une prison pour les
femmes avec des cages avec des
gris
enenghan ça moi j'aime pas les ils n'
pas droit de fermer les écoles des
filles c'est pas l'islam pas
l'islam vous envoyez un garçon dans une
école au bout d'un moment vous avez vous
allez former une personne si vous formez
scolarisez une fille ou former
scolariser une famille et et fermeture
d'école vous savez la richesse d'une
communauté c'est pas les mines c'est la
l' le cerveau en fait le talent les
scolarité j'ai eu l'espoir de retourner
un jour en Afghanistan voilà euh je
pensais que peut-être les talibans ce
sera fini il n'avait pas pas d'autres
problèmes de sécurité tout ça mais
malheureusement vous voyez
que les talibans se sont emparés de
pouvoir euh
et nous ne pouvons pas rentrer en
Afghanistan l'Afghanistan il est situé
c'est un point neutre entre l'Occident
et l'Orient les rousses la zone sous
l'influence des Rousses et la zone sous
l'influence de l'ex empire britannique
et les Américains en fait il y a un qui
vient avance deuxè qui recoule 2è avè
qui recoule donc depuis des siècles la
guerre qui est en cours il y a pas le
bonhe il y a pas com génération il y a
des générations qui sont sacrifié et ça
va continuer jusqu'à quand on sa
[Applaudissements]
pas
quelle est la valeur d'amour pour un fou
s'il n'est pas tombé amourux
OK autour de la flamme il il n pas de î
il n'a pas il n'a pas dansé autour de la
flamme et il ne sait pas la valeur de
l'amour non mais papillon tu parles de
qui je parle de toi non je parle de toi
je parle avec toi il y a pas de î il y a
pas de il y a pas de île je parle avec
toi d'accord
oui la poésie ça ça donne pas la même
sens maintenant vous avez compris le le
le le le sentiment de de ce poème ou pas
au niveau de traduction vous avez
compris ou pas qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ça
veut dire qu'une personne qui est fou et
idiote il ne comprend pas il ne sait pas
la valeur de l'amour s'il est tombé
amoureux
ouais comme un papillon qui tourne
autour de la flamme de tour de autour de
la flamme pourquoi pourquoi il fait la
tour parce qu'il est il est amoureux
amoureux de quoi amoureux de de flamme
oui voilà pour ça
ou elle est tombée à Morau de Flam pour
ça elle brûle brle
voilà mes quatre sœurs actuellement qui
habitent en
Afghanistan mon frère qui habite en
Afghanistan la famille de mon épouse les
frères les sœurs les angles tous tous
Actuellement il habit en Afghanistan il
sont en danger j'ai fait une demande de
protection aussi pour ma famille à la
cellule de Chise du ministère des
Affaires d'étrangères mais
malheureusement j'ai reçu aucune réponse
favorable moi je m sens aussi comme ça
depuis que la guerre a commencé en
ouraine la communauté internationale a
oublié en fait
l'afghanistanallah
charbon non non c'est
pas
la plupart des femmes les interprètes
sur lesquelles on fait le film elles se
cachent elles ne souhait pas être filmé
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
euh les plupart des femmes iles ont
gardé leur culture en région les femmes
ne parlent pas avec les hommes étrangers
avec les hommes et je pense que
maintenant aussi elle n'os pas
j'espère petit à petit et elle commence
à un
peu quoi de sortir d'apprendre la
langue
le
en la s'il vous
plît en tant que père je suis très très
très fier
que mes enfants qui parlaient même pas
cette langue alors la langue française
ils sont arrivés à avoir leur bac
s'inscrire à la fac après c'est eux qui
décident est-ce qu'ils veulent rester
ici avec nous où est-ce qu'il partent
pour l'instant ils sont sur la bonne
[Musique]
route
les parfums ne font pas frissonner sa
narine il dort dans le soleil la main
sur sa poitrine tranquille il a d'autres
rouges au côté
[Musique]
droit